love is in the air everywhere we look
around who is your favorite Disney
couple we're about to show you real life
versions of jasmine and Aladdin Tarzan
and Jane and eight other iconic Disney
couples
wait until you see if your favorite made
the list don't forget to subscribe to
our channel and give this video a big
thumbs up today we're checking out ten
Disney couples in real life Ariel and
Eric let's start with the two that
instantly fell in love but only one of
them had a pair of feet
Ariel first saw Eric on his ship he was
playing with Max the dog who actually
noticed the mermaid taking a peek at the
ship life you could clearly see Ariel
falling for the guy who was also the
first human she ever saw up close after
the storm rocked the ship Ariel saved
Erin and that was the start of the
enchanting love story they're definitely
a cute couple but check out this
real-life couple they decided to
recreate a few scenes dressed as Ariel
and Eric and they did an amazing job
you can find their amazing cosplays at
their deviantART account called Mayumi
love Sora the two really are
relationship goals the woman's name is
Mai you me and she's rockin Ariel's long
red hair while Sora is giving us those
charming Eric vibes the two also cosplay
as several other Disney characters but
we think this look is the absolute best
in the Little Mermaid Ariel longs to be
with humans but did you know her iconic
part of your world song was almost cut
from the movie the directors sprained an
early version of The Little Mermaid to
an audience full of kids and they
noticed the kids got bored at that part
luckily they screened the movie again in
color and part of your world was a
keeper Rapunzel and Flynn Rider these
two are definitely one of the most
interesting Disney couples out there
with quite a new
whole story we can imagine Flynn
explaining how the two met he would
explain that he was running from a Crazy
Horse after stealing a tiara found the
tower Rapunzel was locked up in she
smacked him on the head with a frying
pan and the rest is history the two
didn't realize they had feelings for
each other until about halfway into the
movie but we're so glad they did but it
might shock you when you learn that they
have the biggest age gap out of all
Disney couples Rapunzel's 18 while Flynn
Rider is in his mid-20s regardless of
their age difference
their love story inspired many other
couples including these two who are
Disneyland's official Rapunzel and Flynn
Rider
their outfits have so much detail it's
actually very impressive what else you'd
expect from an actual real-life disney
couple Rapunzel's hair looks absolutely
stunning well Flynn's haircut is styled
in the same way as the actual animated
version the two seem to have the same
chemistry as our beloved tangled couple
and we love it speaking of Rapunzel's
hair did you know that it took about six
to seven years to fully develop her hair
in the movie they didn't know how it was
going to come out until the very last
minute but it's safe to say those seven
years of production have really paid off
Tarzan and Jane so let's move away from
the typical Disney Princesses and their
beloved princes and have a look at some
slightly unusual pairings we were able
to enjoy does I Tarzan's you Jade sound
familiar
we haven't talked much about this Disney
movie on this channel so far but it's
definitely worthy of a mention after all
it is one of the must-see classics
Disney released Tarzan the movie in 1999
the two met when Jane got separated from
her team of human explorers after they
were chased by baboons
Tarzan saved her and after realizing he
was human just like she was the two fell
in love in 2002
Disney followed up on their love with a
sequel called Tarzan and Jane their
names and Tarzan's famous catchphrase
became everyone's favorite pickup line
looks like it really worked for some
couples these two real-life examples of
the unusual pair come straight out of
Disneyland and they look absolutely
amazing
Jane's outfit is spot on and Tarzan is
rocking those dreadlocks the looks of
Tarzan and Jane haven't changed even
after the classic was remade into an
actual movie in 2016
Tarzan is played by Alexander Skarsgard
who joked as the directors didn't have
to do much to his looks to turn him into
his iconic character we have to give him
credit because not a lot of people can
pull off the Tarzan scream woody and Bo
Peep another unusual pairing we
absolutely have to mention is woody and
Bo Peep the two really hit it off when
Andy paired them together woody had to
save Bo Peep and the two later became an
actual couple isn't that the cutest
thing ever this couple decided to
recreate their love and they did a
fantastic job
the images belong to a deviantART user
Ilya and cosplay we're always impressed
with the way cosplayers can make and use
props to recreate their favorite Disney
characters the attention to detail is
often amazing
and we love how these two recreated the
two Toy Story characters in the best way
possible love is definitely in the air
here's some good news for all you Toy
Story fans the director of the movie
confirmed that Toy Story 4 will focus on
woody and Bo peeps romance Disney fall
is an interesting rule when it comes to
sequels they don't make another movie
unless they come up with a storyline
that's just as good or even better it's
safe to say that we're in for a
rollercoaster story if it's going to
focus on these two lovebirds the news
about the feature started a few years
ago and you'll finally be able to catch
Toy Story 4 in cinemas in 2019
Cinderella and Prince Charming and who
could forget about the ultimate
relationshipgoals couple every little
girl dreams of meeting her very own
version of Prince Charming and we all
have Cinderella to thank for that name
the story of Cinderella completely
enchanted the world and we all cheered
on Prince
charming as he went on a quest to find
the owner of the glass slipper and the
two lived happily ever after the true
real-life Cinderella and Prince Charming
are of course the performers you can
catch at Disneyland
they really do bring you a cinematic
Cinderella experience and they're just
so cute just like Tarzan and Jane
Cinderella and Prince Charming also got
their very own movie remake in 2015 you
can now catch a human version of the
pair played by Lily James and Richard
Madden who portrayed an excellent
version of Prince Charming
speaking of Prince Charming do you know
his actual name don't worry if you don't
because neither do we although there are
many fan theories and rumors floating
around Prince Charming's name is still
unknown along with the Beast and the
prince from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs he's the only Disney Prince
without an official name come on
Disney doesn't he deserve to have a name
after all this time Pocahontas and John
Smith out of all the love stories we're
showing you today this one is actually
based on a true story unfortunately it
was much sadder than the one we saw in
our favorite movie Pocahontas was only a
child when she met John Smith and the
Europeans did terrible things to her
before she married another John John
Rolfe so this time we think that the
cartoon version of this man is actually
the best but that didn't keep people
from rewriting this story and turning
John into a man who actually deserves
the chance to meet the Native American
woman the images you're about to see
belong to a brilliant deviantART
cosplayer Chinglish he recreated a
pretty impressive version of John Smith
and his friends could definitely play
the part of Pocahontas kudos for getting
John Smith's hair to stay in the right
shape we can't imagine how much
hairspray he had to use to reach this
style do you want to hear something cool
Irene Bedard the actress that voiced
Pocahontas was also used as a
live-action model Irene said that her
two-year-old easily recognizes her
movements in Pocahontas when they're
watching the movie Irene also confirmed
why Pocahontas is one of the strongest
Disney Princesses she doesn't wait for
her prince
and doesn't need him to tell this story
in fact Pocahontas is the one that saved
John Smith in the first place we
definitely love her
independent attitude Beauty and the
Beast if you ever want to catch Beauty
and the Beast in real life you
absolutely have to visit Disneyland you
might just spot them randomly walking
down the street like it's no big deal
Beauty and the Beast is a story of true
love and a life lesson that the beauty
really lies on the inside Belle could
have gone with a strong and mighty but
also terribly arrogant Gaston but her
heart was set on the Beast Beauty and
the Beast was released in 1991 but Walt
Disney actually had the idea for the
story in the 1930s and wanted to create
it in the 1950s but the story was too
difficult to bring to life at that time
did you know that the song human again
was only added in the 2002 re-release
but was originally cut from the movie
right before the production it's one of
our favorite songs from the film the
iconic classic has several live-action
movies including a 1946 edition which
was an inspiration for Disney's version
you've probably heard of the 2017 remake
of the movie right you don't have to go
to Disneyland to see the two characters
as humans Emma Watson and Dan Stevens
probably play the best real-life
versions of Beauty and the Beast and
they're incredible to watch Tiana and
Prince Naveen the story of these two is
quite an interesting one
they were both frogs at some point and
you think Tiana would never fall for
someone who turned her into a frog but
true love really shows no boundaries
we're actually impressed that Tiana's
hard work and life values finally rubbed
off on Prince Naveen at the end of the
story we'd love to see what the two are
doing now you can actually find the real
life Princess Tiana and Prince Naveen at
Disneyland and they are just as cute as
the actual animated version we love
Prince Naveen smile
Tiana's story received a lot of praise
and she's not your regular princess
besides Pocahontas she's probably one of
the most independent and hard-working
characters
on our list she knows what she wants but
she also knows she has to work hard to
get it not many princesses dream of
owning a restaurant but that's precisely
why Tiana is so unique the directors of
the movie described Tiana as someone
who's warm and vulnerable but with a lot
of backbone she doesn't give in to
things very easily and it took a while
before she warmed up to her version of
Prince Charming Snow White and the
prince
speaking of nameless princes will
probably never find out the name of the
prince in Snow White in the Seven Dwarfs
someday my prince will come our 14 year
old Snow White's lyrics as she's singing
to the Seven Dwarves and her prince
really did come and much like everyone
else they lived happily ever after and
yes Snow White was just 14 when she met
her almost 18 year old Prince but let's
ignore that fact and show you some real
life of age examples of these two
classic love birds if you want to find a
live version of Snow White in the prince
you'll have to visit Disneyland where
you'll get absolutely enchanted because
the two really do look like the real
deal did you know that Snow White and
the Seven Dwarfs is the first animated
Disney movie ever it's the one that
started it all and made us fall in love
with Disney couples producing this movie
was a huge gamble for Walt Disney as he
had no idea how it'll be perceived by
the public we're so happy Disney
followed his dreams and created the
movies we know and love today and we bet
at least one of you got this someday my
prince will come song stuck in your head
jasmine and Aladdin and last but not
least it's the two that brought us a
whole new world of adventures on a magic
carpet jasmine and Aladdin are one of
the most popular Disney couples out
there we can certainly see why the two
share quite a powerful chemistry
combined with Jasmine sassiness and
Aladdin's mischievous character the two
are a perfect match it looks like that
jasmine and Aladdin from Disneyland are
just as happily in love is the
version of the two lovebirds speaking of
Aladdin did you know that Tom Cruise was
a huge inspiration behind his character
and did you know that the animator
behind the movie had no idea how to draw
jasmine until he noticed his sister had
a particularly interesting hairstyle in
a high school photo Disney animators
really pull off inspiration from just
about anywhere and we can't wait to see
what they'll come up with next what we'd
really love to see is a real-life
jasmine and Aladdin flying on an actual
magic carpet instead of their floating
boat during the disneyland Parade we
just can't get over how cute they look
and we hope real love sparks are flying
between these two if there's one thing
we learned today is that all you need is
love and a bit of cosplay and you'll be
able to become a real life Disney couple
which Disney couple is your favorite let
us know in the comments for more Disney
mania check out ten Disney Princesses
reimagined as monsters see you next time
[Music]